welcome to this video playing gender the
end from the Netherlands own I don't
remember what this guy is normally
playing I have played them three times
recently okay we get a field chateau in
thought and not something that I know
very well but let's see what what I can
make up with the board really really
always to a5 them yeah not much was like
can we nee 194 don't lead to much I
guess Bishop d to push up it was also no
good
I is going to play c6 still feels a bit
but it still feels a bit weird to me
what is doing here maybe this is a total
hidden online but looks a bit strange
okay if I go just b 3b 3b should be
three maybe I should prevent Bishop
g-form this does make some sense i guess
i don't want to have him put the bishop
there then okay so um can I go be three
yeah I guess be free I wanted to play
Bishop b3 to d4 but he has Knight to f5
that's not good hmm ok so maybe here
Queen d2 Bishop 86 ideas like that I
still shouldn't be in bad shape I mean I
have a good centralized position night
you for is this coming or maybe better
get out of the diagonal
now I might I might be able to play 94
also
so that he has to think about retreating
the bishop but also just Bishop h6 comes
into consideration trade off this good
Bishop and really okay it seems that is
really afraid of g4 and he wants to
prepare that okay so let's take and now
consider queen d 4 + move I really
always wanted to play 94 okay just do
this my idea always was 94 and then
rookie one rookie three this the type of
setup okay is trying to double on the C
file what about f3 and tending g-form is
this nonsense my beam
hmm I really don't like it very much
that he can double on the sea far but
don't see what to do against that rook
c8 rookie one cookie 3s my plan it's
still very M nicely centralized I over
protect your five reliably ok so now I
thought rookie three nights Eve for too
smooth not sure takes Knight takes Queen
moose yeah cannot really evaluate this
at the moment ok it's not it's not going
for it and now I wanted to if possible
retreat here the c3 night or I can
actually go to be five hour k takes
takes rook c2 as possible right each
other's 94
I don't see a good way to improve him he
also doesn't but you please he can play
some some quick moves night a4 b6 now
was my idea I'm controlling all relevant
squares efore d5 controlled this this
looks okay of course that's the usual
time issue take or let him take maybe
use the long diagonal can I get higher
in some sort of tactic here may be here
and Knight to e5 the g4 it could be a
good good way to regroup
I have phone just runs into Queen g7 I
still have a good good pressure against
against the e pawn and maybe I shouldn't
have allowed the trade check I'm just
winning this rook know or not black exam
yeah this was a bit lucky considering
the time situation the position was okay
for me and it was very good before but
it down it saw the typical scenario with
me spending lots of time in a good
position here white wins with an ID f5
is winning why it takes 96 okay this is
very strong yes it's very strong Knight
takes 95 and this is this is fatal now
for black he needs to remove the rooks
somewhere and then here black is
collapsing those two those two nights I
just I just something getting lost it
would have been a very nice finish of
this game yeah I didn't I didn't see
that I only saw this which is also good
but not ultimately convincing not a five
again is strong yeah I simply I didn't
see the idea to play these six once
again very strong with 95 coming very
nice now I didn't see that this just
gives up most of the advantage which
pretty much was clear when I played it
but okay you need to need to play with
50 seconds yeah I mean I still have this
this nice-looking pressure on the EVO at
night fi
is really a good defense here you can
play rook c8 or maybe trade on C to
enter there's not that much going on
it's it's okay for white but I don't
have anything good anymore Queen jessica
is just blundering blundering the rook
okay thanks for watching